welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness's wildest
contribution to the mcu has got to be
the illuminati something we knew would
be in this movie based on trailers
months ago but uh not like this not like
this
spoilers ahead because uh yeah these are
the biggest reveals of the movie even if
they don't make it out of the movie yes
r.i.p to the illuminati and really r.i.p
to the baxter foundation night janitor
who's about to have a heart attack at
the start of his shift what am i
stepping in is this fruit by the foot oh
my god no it's jim halbert but despite
this girl the witch butchering the
illuminati this movie smartly made this
the illuminati not of the entire
multiverse but of merely one dimension
earth838 a universe that america chavez
even says sucks the history of this
universe their war with thanos what they
learned about the darkhold and what cool
[ __ ] exists in their universe actually
tells us a lot about marvel studios next
moves here in good old earth 616. so
let's break down what we learned from
this illuminati and which of them might
return doctor strange in american chavez
arrive in earth 838 a utopian manhattan
running on clean energy yet horrendously
muted fashion confusing traffic signs
creepy memory banks that are your dirty
laundry on a crowded street corner and
pizza balls that you gotta pay for the
doctor strange of this universe is
immortalized as a hero who gave his life
defeating thanos with the replacement
source for supreme as baron carl mordo
now having his full name from the comics
a member of the illuminati a super group
of marvel leaders from the various
factions of marvel universe who come
together to defend earth and really just
have all the brightest minds in one room
so alongside mordo you got captain
carter the first avenger implying other
avengers do exist in this universe maria
rambo defender of the cosmos black agar
balticon aka black bolt ruler of the
inhumans and keeper of the terrigen mist
the smartest man alive reed richards of
the fantastic four and professor charles
xavier of the x-men they work in the
baxter foundation of building in central
park its name and not of the fantastic
forest baxter building its interior
modeled on the british museum of london
and it's run by ultron centuries which
might mean that this universe has a tony
stark who did invent the ultron tech in
616 or this could be a universe like in
the comics where ultron was actually
created by hank pym there is a seventh
empty seat on that deus and even though
they said there were no other members of
the illuminati i don't know why they
would keep it there if it didn't belong
to some past member of this group and
they revealed the truth that their
doctor strange actually went rogue
during their infinity war conflict with
thanos using the darkhold to dreamwalk
in the multiverse seeking a solution
this is a lot like the 616 doctor
strange using the time stone to glance
ahead at 14 605 future outcomes but
instead of possible futures this guy
projected his consciousness into fully
separate universes and doing that caused
an incursion that mysteriously killed
everyone in that universe charles says
that 838 steven renounced the darkhold
and helped them find the book of the
shanti which they did use together to
defeat thanos and for this charles uses
his telepathy to project into strange's
mind taking all of us to that memory on
titan where thanos is dead with his
double-bladed weapon plunged into his
chest now they don't see how the book of
ashanti did that so much for it being a
book of defensive spells but if you look
closely at his infinity gauntlet like in
the 616 battle of titan thanos had
acquired the power stone the space stone
the reality stone in the soul stone but
not yet the time stone and the mind
stone presumably the book of ashanti was
powerful enough to overcome those four
stones in particular maybe tapping into
the reality stone or the soul stone
counteracting that particular magic just
enough for one of them to stab him with
his own weapon now that sword is made
out of uru according to the russo
brothers the same knit of valyrian metal
that ichri casts stormbreaker out of and
stormbreaker was able to overcome a
blast from all six stones to break
thanos's skin like hats that were only
gone for the head right so one book of
ashanti spell disabling one to four
stones plus reed richards i guess
slingshotting thanos sword back into his
chest done and done now the illuminati
go on to say that the darkhold had
corrupted strange so much that they made
black bolts kill him and that corruption
is evidenced by 838 strange's fingertips
turned black just like wandas and
agatha's now the scarlet witch kills
them well she kills five of them carl
mordo's still trying to climb out of
that weird moat they build into their
judging room but do with their deaths
also die our dreams for mcu x-men
fantastic four in humans other caps
starring these faces of course not the
specific way these illuminati members
were written and designed guarantees we
will see some if not all of them again
now if i ever seem tired it's because
there are some tough nights when i'm
working late i have to get up early the
next morning to finish a video my
limited sleep time is precious and i
wanted to be high quality and you need a
nice dark bench room for good sleep and
it can be hard sometimes to get a
bedroom completely dark and that is
where the blue blocks of blackout sleep
masks come in handy now we know blue
blocks from their blue light blocking
glasses their sleep mask blocks out 100
of light for better sleep it's very soft
and has adjustable eye caps and an
adjustable strap for the perfect fit it
works for people who sleep on their
belly on their side or on their back hey
hey
where did everyone go not that i'm
complaining they're made from a
breathable material so your face and
your eyes just feel nice and comfortable
this thing is so great for improving
sleep or meditation or napping and
travel i love using it when i want to
sleep in or grab a nap during the day i
use it whenever i'm on an airplane and
the jerk next to me has to look out the
window and all the mountains they ship
worldwide and have other great products
like red light therapy devices so go to
blueblocks.com new rockstars and use a
coupon code new rockstars to save 20
that's blueblox.com
dot com slash new rockstars and use a
coupon code new rockstars to save 20
when 616 strange first heard fantastic
four he quipped didn't you guys chart in
the 60s now strange is obviously making
fun of their group name comparing them
to the beatles and interestingly bruce
banner did the same thing with the
avengers infinity war broke up like a
band like like the beatles and in
spider-man no way home when toby maguire
peter parker heard the name the avengers
he also thought they were a band the
avengers yeah that's great thank you
what is that well you don't have the
avengers is that a bad are you in a band
now read richard smiles at this joke and
this comparison should remind us of
ant-man director peyton reed saying he
once pitched a fantastic war movie as a
60s period piece like the beatles movie
a hard day's night and i pitched several
theories based on that on this channel
of how that history could actually be
true in the mcu with hank pym who was
active during the 60s having lost some
other scientist friends to the quantum
realm which might be the mcu's version
the negative zone and then spitting them
back out in the present day something
that might even come up in quantum mania
now again i think 616 strange was just
joking about charting in the 60s but
there still could totally be an mcu
reality where that was the actual
history of the fantastic war like
america chavez says that there's an
actual reality where wang is running
naked from a clown we could totally have
this version of the fantastic war and
also wanda asked reed if he has a wife
and children and he says yeah referring
to sue storm franklin richards and
valeria richards lineage that will lead
one day to nathaniel richards aka kang
the conqueror in the 31st century kang
will not only appear in quantum mania in
loki season 2 but moon knight overtly
referenced kang twice and a kang variant
seems likely to appear in any young
avengers title this guy's about to show
up everywhere and it was just reported
that john watts is stepping down from
directing the mcu fantastic four movie
which might open things up for john
krasinski to direct and maybe star and
now krysinski doesn't have to be the
only reed richards variant in the mcu
could have lots of different actors
playing them really especially since in
the comics we are used to seeing minnie
reeds i mean until you start getting
multiple smartest guys in the room in
the room i take reed richards isn't that
interesting of a character that's just
me that's just me i love what krasinski
did with it i just think reed richards
belongs in a multiverse rather than just
a verse now we will probably see haley
atwell captain carter again as she has
been confirmed to be a focal character
of what if season 2 and the fact that
live action haley's suit and shield
looked exactly like the animation tells
us that marvel likely has plans to
explore her in live action captain
carter from a different dimension would
make a great member of a captain britain
corps which also seems like a pretty
good place to bring back chris evans if
those reports were true now lashawna
lynch captain marvel we'll see
wanovision left that interesting mystery
of maria rambo's cancer during the blip
which might have been connected to
monica's powers which she wasn't planned
to have before westview patrick stewart
charles xavier nance and mount
blackbull's obviously mutants
intelligent missed inhumans aren't
coming to the mcu but these actors i'm
not sure they deliberately put charles
in his animated x-men attire and yellow
hover chair and his entrance music was
ron wasserman's fox x-men series theme
in black bolt and abc's short-lived in
human series never really had that
tuning fork headgear like this one did
i'm just thinking these two might be fan
service wings to the pasteras not
necessarily signs of marvel studios
actual mutant plan folks there is a
multiverse of other universes to explore
beyond earth 838 though i am curious to
know what happens to 838 christine a38
mordo and whoever's chair that was
really the biggest clue though was the
word incursion which came up again in
the post-credits scene with clia and
likely some of these fallen illuminati
faces will respawn with the rest of the
mcu heroes in an avengers secret wars
event time will tell you can follow me
on instagram and twitter at eavos follow
new rockstars subscribe to the rockstars
for more analysis of everything you love
thanks for watching bye
[Music]
foreign
[Music]